>> Let's go through each one of these. With this first one, we take the square
root of the average square deviation. Well, the deviation is x i minus x bar.
The square deviation is then just x i minus x bar squared, and the average is
summing each squared deviation up and then dividing by n. And this is our
formula for standard deviation. The average square deviation is basically this
inside the square root sign, but then instead of taking the square root, we
square it. This is not the standard deviation. The sum of square deviations,
well these are the square deviations so the sum is just this. Remember that this
is also called sum of squares. Sum of absolute deviations squared, the absolute
deviation is xi minus x bar with the absolute values, and if we square them
that's the same as if we didn't take the absolute value. And then if we take the
sum, we get the sum of squares again, so these two are equivalent, and they're
not the standard deviation. Finally, we have the sum of squared deviations,
divided by n, and then the square root of that. So that is also our formula for
standard deviation. Good job. I know this was really hard.